the president is raising the stakes for
trade talks with China that resumed
today in Washington that last night's
rally he repeated a threat to raise
tariffs on Chinese goods if there is no
deal any of his China pulling back on
promises and putting those talks in
jeopardy
they broke the deal they can't do that
so they'll be paying we don't make the
deal nothing wrong with taking in over a
hundred billion dollars a year China
said overnight it will retaliate for any
tariff increase if there's no deal the
trade conflict could cost US consumers
billions we have breaking news from the
Vatican Pope Francis has issued a
groundbreaking new law to combat sex
abuse in the church
starting next month all priests and nuns
will be required to report abuse and
cover-ups including those of their
superiors to church authorities Seth
Doane is in Alba Italy with the historic
push for a reform
Seth good morning this is big this is
big good morning these are the most
concrete steps that we have seen so far
coming from the Vatican following that
landmark sex abuse summit they had on
clerical sex abuse
back in February today's sweeping
guidelines cover the issues of sexual
abuse of minors child pornography and
importantly the abuse of power which
would apply to a seminarian or a nun
significantly the guidelines address the
issue of covering up abuse and require
all priests and nuns to promptly report
it the protocols are also global
applying to the entire church Pope
Francis is mandating every diocese must
establish an office to deal with abuse
and to develop a way for people to
easily and confidentially report it it
lays out clear procedures timeframes
responsibilities and puts the onus on
the Vatican to respond quickly the
church investigations put the archbishop
in charge but remember former Cardinal
Theodore McCarrick held that office and
he was dismissed from the priesthood for
sexual misconduct so now there are new
guidelines to bypass that office if
necessary now notably it does not
mandate lay involvement that is the
involvement of Catholics outside of the
church hierarchy but it does leave up to
each individual diocese the ability to
involve laypeople if they are so
interested Gail says Doe
reporting from Italy thank you